bonsoir le journal de tv soixante dix
huit pour faire le tour de l'actualité
locale bienvenue dans cette édition
voici les titres de ce mercredi 9
septembre
depuis le confinement le trafic des
pistes cyclables a augmenté de 29% en
france où le nombre de locations de
vélos a également explosé en cette
rentrée ce que le boom se confirme dans
les yvelines
reportage une bulle d'air pur dans les
cours de récréation ce dispositif qui
capte les polluants et testé en ce
moment à l'école victor hugo de poissy
une première qui pourrait être
prochainement installés dans les gares
et aéroports de la région
et puis notre page dédiée à la
législative partielle dans la 11e
circonscription premier tour dimanche 20
septembre
onze candidats sont en lice pour le
scrutin parmi eux jérémy disait engagé
avec france écologie alors que les
laboratoires sont surchargées que les
chiffres du comité 19 sont à la hausse
dans la région ile de france on apprend
aujourd'hui que 20 centres de dépistages
vont ouvrir prochainement dans la région
est déployée par la rs ces sites seront
capables de réaliser dix mille
prélèvements par jour ils seront ouverts
jusqu'à la fin de l'hiver et seront
répartis dans les huit départements
franciliens et les emplacements exacts
ne sont pas encore connues et les
personnes pourront se rendre sur place
sans rendez vous de 8 heures à 19 heures
des plages horaires réservées pour les
cas asymptomatiques lé dispositif vient
compléter les 591 points de prélèvement
déjà installés dans la région et
d'ailleurs toujours dans cette
thématique olivier ferrand le ministre
de la santé a annoncé hier est la mise
en place de nouveaux dépistage en
ile-de-france des tests dits antigénique
est le principe reste le même que pour
le dépistage pcr des prélèvements sont
réalisés dans les narines
mais ce procès des repères des protéines
du virus en quelques minutes seulement
ces tests vont être mis en place à
l'assistance publique hôpitaux de paris
pas de dépistage salivaire prévu en
revanche pour le moment qu'ils sont
encore en phase d'expérimentation
elle la petite reine est elle en passe
d'être couronné définitivement comme
moyen de transport préféré des français
cela reste à confirmer mais le vélo
c'est une certitude et de plus en plus
utilisés en ile-de-france depuis le
déconfinement le constat est même dressé
du côté des boutiques spécialisées le
reportage de nicolas landry
c'est le moyen de transport phare du
déconfinement le vélo connaît un franc
succès dans ce magasin le constat est
clair une augmentation de près de 30%
des ventes depuis le 11 mai envie de
s'évader de prendre un petit peu d'aller
voir un petit peu la nature mais aussi
envie de se déplacer autrement peut-être
ne pas prendre les transports en commun
voilà de changer un petit peu de mode
mode de mode de vie mode de déplacement
ou les clients achètent aussi des vélos
assez polyvalent pour justement faire un
petit peu tout une pratique loisir une
pratique vélo taf
même phénomène dans cet autre enseigne
une croissance de 60% du chiffre
d'affaires depuis le déconfinement un
vélo sur deux vendus et électriques
plusieurs utilisations les déplacements
pour aller au travail faire ses courses
ou se balader
aujourd'hui on commence à avoir un peu
de mal à avoir certaines certaine à pro
il va y avoir les certains fabricants
nous annonce quand même
un trou sur la fin de l'année sur le
vélo aujourd'hui on a aussi le flux du
coup de monter les vélos qui sont déjà
en magasin et dès qu'un vélo est monté
il part dans la semaine dans la région
il ya plein de bois il ya des pistes
cyclables qui sont chantier plus de 200
kilomètres de pistes cyclables très très
privilégiés protégés jusqu'à lui offrir
du vélo en famille donc assez
naturellement
eh bien les ventes de vélos suivent les
infrastructures cyclables suivent le
mouvement les intercommunalités s'engage
notamment dans cette voie c'est le cas
de l'agglomération versailles grand parc
et le développement d'un réseau de 72 km
de pistes cyclables les associations
vélo sur le territoire qui prennent de
plus en plus d'envergure avec qui on
essaie de discuter au quotidien pour
faire avancer tous ces sujets est vrai
que la crise est venue accélérer ce
mouvement là autre exemple d'engagement
le 27 mai dernier la région ile de
france a voté une enveloppe de 300
millions d'euros
objectif développer le rer vélo pour
relier paris à la grande couronne via un
réseau de pistes cyclables
cet accord trouvé entre l'état et
ile-de-france mobilité une subvention
exceptionnelle va être octroyée au
syndicat qui gère les transports dans la
région 1,4 milliard d'euros remboursable
sur 16 ans pour compenser les pertes
liées au confinement et à la crise
sanitaire cette enveloppe va permettre
de continuer les investissements sur le
réseau et d'éviter une hausse des tarifs
pour les usagers a précisé la présidente
de la région valérie pécresse et
franciliens vont donc peut-être pouvoir
avec le vélo et les transports davantage
se passer de leur voiture rappelons que
91 % de la population mondiale
elle respire un air pollué d'après un
dernier rapport de l' oms à poissy un
dispositif permettant de créer une bulle
d'air curé testé en ce moment dans une
cour d'école les précisions avec ce
sujet de célia gars de son go et justine
brasier prendre les cours d'écoles moins
polluer c'est l'objectif de ce
dispositif innovant installé depuis une
semaine dans la cour de récréation de
l'école victor hugo à poissy dans le
cadre de la journée internationale de
l'air pur lundi 7 septembre la
présidente de la région ile de france le
maire de la ville
la directrice générale adjointe de suez
sont venus nombreux le reste est à
chinon qui permet de créer une bulle
d'air pur pour les enfants ce dispositif
va donc permettre de capter de nombreux
polluants l'équivalent de ceux qui
émettent en moyenne 550 véhicule sur un
trajet franciliens quotidien les
particules fines pm10 et pm2 nmi/pmi ça
va être aussi le dioxyde d'azoté
le no2 et ça va être aussi les composés
organiques volatils mais c'est vrai
c'est les polluants principaux qu'on
retrouve dans les villes et aussi dans
les écoles en juillet 2020 l'état a été
condamné pour son inaction concernant la
pollution de l'air alors pour encourager
ces projets environnementaux
la région ile-de-france a mis sur la
table 500 millions d'euros grâce au
budget participatif environnemental de
la région toutes les communes qui
décideraient de se lancer pour
développer ce dispositif pourront
déposer des projets et pourront se faire
financer ce dispositif
pour ce premier essai l'école victor
hugo en plein centre de poissy n'a pas
été choisi au hasard on en plein coeur
du centre-ville où il ya des milliers
des milliers de voitures qui traversent
la ville comme les poids lourds qui
n'ont rien à faire ici en matière de
circulation de transit
on a choisi ici parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de passage et on veut pouvoir montrer
qu'on peut purifier l'air avec des idées
qui sont innovants ses premiers
dispositifs tests s'ils fonctionnent
pourrait se retrouver prochainement dans
des gares dans les métros ou d'en ouvrir
par france gall cette plainte contre x a
déposé par le maire de carrières sous
poissy eddie ait l'élu dénonce une
pollution aux métaux lourds
une mise en danger de la vie d'autrui et
atteinte à l'environnement causée par la
mer de déchets cette décharge sauvage
qui s'est étendue jusqu'à 350 hectares
sur la plaine entre carrière et triel
sur seine pour l'élu le lieu est devenu
je cite les goûts géant de la capitale
depuis la fin du 19e siècle un site et
de surcroît dangereux avec la présence
sur place de traces de plomb et
d'arsenic
l'objectif de cette action c'est de
faire payer les pollueurs pour la remise
en état du site
cet été pour précisions le département
des yvelines a effectué sur place un
chantier de dépollution d'une première
parcelle pages politiques à présent dans
ce journal avec la une nouvelle inc
review dans le cadre de la campagne aux
législatives partielles dans la 11e
circonscription des yvelines
l'entretien a été enregistrée hier mardi
[Musique]
11 candidats sur la ligne de départ pour
cette élection législative partielle
c'est le 20 septembre prochain pour le
premier tour dans la 11e circonscription
des yvelines éventuel la deuxième tour
le 27 septembre une élection rendue
nécessaire après la démission de nadia
qui est devenu ministre délégué à la
ville
et parmi ces onze candidats jérémy
blizzard est avec moi en visio bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le candidat de france
écologie pour ce scrutin vice président
de cette formation politique vous n'en
n'êtes pas à votre première campagne
puisque vous étiez présent sur une liste
candidate à cerner la ville lors des
dernières municipales vous avez est
également candidat en 2017
lors de l'élection législative dans la
2e circonscription vous avez vous aviez
recueilli 1,29 pour cent des voix
candidat également en 2012 dans la 11e
circonscription avec un résultat de -2
1% des voix pourquoi cette nouvelle
candidature et pourquoi cette fois ci
dans la 11e circonscription des yvelines
tout d'abord pour qu'il y ait une
candidature écologiste qui puisse
rassembler l'ensemble des citoyens des
électeurs qui souhaitent exprimer pour
une créature écologistes en 100% une
créature qui va au delà des clivages
habituels droite gauche dans laquelle
souvent sans faire de l'écologie pour
qu'on ne soit pas des faire valoir d'un
programme
mais qu'on soit un programme écologiste
pas que sur l'environnement notre
éducation la santé la culture sur
l'ensemble des thématiques qu'on puisse
avoir un vrai projet écologiste a parce
que si on parle d'un autre parti europe
ecologie les verts ce parti soutient une
autre candidature celle de sandrine
granby il faut davantage parler
d'écologie vous le dit c'est pas la
sphère de clivages politiques
et ça absolument lorsqu'aujourd'hui le
clivage droite gauche comme on
l'entendait il n'y a encore pas
longtemps n'a plus vraiment de sens
aujourd'hui la question écologiste a
repris au coeur de beaucoup de citoyens
et dépasse les clivages et des gens de
droite
ne se reconnaissent d'ailleurs ni en
demi de droite ni de gauche qui sont
écologistes et je veux par ces
prédateurs porter un discours qui puisse
les rassembler tout ce n'est pas dire
non vous droite donc des risques mais on
a vu que cette thématique était centrale
dans les dernières municipales est ce
qu'elle est devenue davantage la crise
sanitaire et ce qu'elle a fait prendre
aussi conscience à votre avis de tout
l'enjeu climatique aussi puisque on a vu
pendant cette crise sanitaire et pendant
le confinement que les choses pouvaient
s'améliorer avec de petits gestes au
quotidien
absolument je pense que la crise qu'on
vient de vivre qui n'est malheureusement
pas terminé a permis à beaucoup de gens
de retrouver la proximité vous pouvez
plus allé loin on est obligé d'aller
dans les commerces de proximité dans des
chaires demandé dans des boucheries
attendait creamer et on a retrouvé ce
goût du local et surtout son goût de la
qualité et je pense qu'il serait dommage
fin de cette crise qu'on reprenne les
mêmes études cadre la campagne
municipale a effectivement donné pas mal
de voix aux écologistes rassemblés ou
pas je pense à certaines listes de la
france à nice où il ya une liste qui a
regroupé je pense 100% des partis
politiques dolly qui est un des
meilleurs résultats en france milite
écologistes il ya la preuve que quand on
se rassemble on est capable de porter
haut et fort les couleurs écologistes
pas besoin d'être à faire valoir notre
parti pour cette édition initiative
malheureusement mais voilà je pense que
les citoyens les électeurs ont vraiment
envie de pouvoir exprimer une volonté
écologistes au delà des clivages
alors les idées vous avez envie de
porter vous en avez parlé celle du
circuit court les commerces de proximité
sont des choses que vous avez envie de
porter de de mettre en avant si vous
êtes d'avant de d'aventuré lui à
l'assemblée nationale d'autant plus que
là le mandat sera très court c'est une
élection partielle
donc on aura compris un an et demi de
mandat je pense qu'en un an et demi il
faut au delà des grands discours des
grandes thématiques de projets sur des
plusieurs années il faut vraiment
essayer de la portée des idées concrètes
pour un an et demi ni
effectivement essayé de promouvoir la
grille l'agriculture biologique les
commerces de proximité et circuits
courts et comment on peut le faire
la fiscalité par exemple à ce qu'on
pourrait pas baisser la tva sur les
produits qui sont bio locaux avoir été
la plus faible pour les produits locaux
encourager notre artisanat nous les
décollages de proximité ces gens qui
travaillent qui sont à fond pour leur
métier qui sont passionnés les aider
face aux géants de l'agroalimentaire
genre l'agroalimentaire et de tout ce
circuit qui les étouffe et qui souvent
n'est en fait sûrement un mot rapide
juste pour terminer sur la manière de
mener campagne on sait que c'est un
contexte particulier avec cette crise
sanitaire comment aller à la rencontre
des électeurs malgré ces ce contexte ce
sera compliqué ça c'est sûr déjà la
campagne est très courte été informé à
cette date de l'élection
je pense que la meilleure manière de
faire campagne pour rencontrer genre
cessera soirée marché faire du
porte-à-porte aller à la rencontre des
gens dans les commerces où on n'a pas
trop le plat si l'on doit être limité je
pense que c'est pas une bonne idée
[Musique]
les électeurs là avance le pense
essentiellement se baser sur les
documents qui brossent voir et sur les
médias pour diffuser les programmes des
candidats ont ce malheureusement de peu
l'occasion pendant cette campagne de
voir les gens surtout pas car on est
tous en activité pour les gens comme moi
qui travaille dans son activité donc
c'est pas forcément simple ans même
d'aller sur le terrain
merci
du temps des gens merci jérémy bizet
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes le candidat de france écologie
pour cette élection législative
partielle dans la 12e circonscription
des yvelines premier tour le dimanche 20
septembre
[Musique]
un retour en direct pour parler
consommation c'est une pratique en
pleine expansion le marché de
l'alimentation végétarienne et vegan
elle devrait augmenter de 17% entre 2019
et 2021 dans les yvelines un premier
service de vente à emporter a ouvert à
bois d'arcy ce fast-food vegan est un
concept pour le moment unique dans le
département
présentation avec ingrid boinet et
miquel et demi d'euros depuis des années
antoine hébert sheller souhaitait
partager son amour pour la cuisine vegan
mais ce n'est qu'en juillet dernier que
ce professeur d'histoire géographie et
sa femme karima se lance dans cette
aventure à mi temps les deux passionnés
ont depuis développé un fast-food vegan
à emporter à bois d'arcy le premier dans
les yvelines
ça fait longtemps qu'on a dans nos
habitudes on a réduit énormément les
tous les produits d'origine animale et
on est très contents des petits plats
des petits menus conséquences et des
hamburgers à la maison est végétarien
avec des frites ou des kebabs et on
s'est dit mais pourquoi pas faire
partager ce plaisir
aux autres en faisant un petit service
de restauration rapide vegan c'est après
un accident qui aurait pu mal tourner
quand one et karima décide d'ouvrir le
service de restauration rapide on a eu
un incendie chez nous donc tout cet
étage là étaient ravagées et on s'est
dit peut-être le moment de reconstruire
on va en profiter pour lancer le projet
ici donc pas de viande mais des simili
carnet des fausses viande à base de
protéines de soja de blé ou de poids
l'objectif est de diminuer leur
consommation pour limiter l'empreinte
environnementale
c'est les valeurs qu'on compte défendre
les valeurs c'est la santé et la planète
et c'est aussi une façon de proposer une
alternative et aider les gens qui
veulent faire un transit rend une
transition nos produits font font penser
à de la viande quoi donc ceux qui
veulent retrouver les plaisirs de la
viande est entré et j'ai envie de dire
en précisant une viande de très bonne
qualité gustative et nutritionnelle
on est là pour répondre à cette demande
là au menu kebab odeurs burger ou une
formule à 12 euros
en attendant la réouverture en septembre
les deux gérants s'offre quelques jours
de repos bien mérité à la rentrée
antoine souhaite continuer son emploi de
professeur tout en ouvrant une à deux
fois par semaine en ce début du mois de
septembre les associations locales aussi
font leur rentrée une reprise après
l'arrêt total des activités engendrée
par le confinement à elancourt le
traditionnel forum se tenait samedi
dernier au complexe sportif de l'europe
marquage au sol stands plus espacés 30%
d'association en moins sur l'événement
pour respecter les mesures sanitaires
une partie du rendez vous se déroulait
d'ailleurs sur internet
une rentrée dans le flou pour les
associations qui ont dû y mettre en
place des protocoles et redoutent aussi
une baisse de leurs adhérents et de
leurs adhérents les propos recueillis
par patrick jacques de dixmude faut
surtout pas baisser le niveau d'activité
est là même si le masque bien sûr été
ritalin est un frein à l'activité mais
on maintient il trouve tous des
solutions fait les associations ce
extraordinaire ils sont elles sont
créatives
elle invente des solutions elles
trouvent des solutions même nous mêmes
on trouve pas c'était un poumon
à laboratoire d'idées et d'actions
extraordinaire pour nous on va délimiter
un périmètre qui sera le périmètre de
pratiques et le périmètre qu'on va dire
public dans le périmètre public c'est
masque obligatoire c'est les mêmes
contraintes chacun amènera son matériel
personnel on devra désinfecter tout ce
qui est commun c'était particulièrement
inquiet sur la reprise des activités en
tant que prof en me demandant si elle
est à voir ou pas des élèves alors
qu'aux inscriptions et c'est très
rassurant ce matin moi j'ai presque tous
mes cours qui sont complets ici à
elancourt il ya une fuite d'adhérents
peut-être un petit peu mais en réalité a
quand même beaucoup de personnes qui
cherchent à vous d'être créé du lien on
va reprendre du contact culture la
deuxième édition du festival et hall est
bien maintenue l'événement se déroule du
18 au 20 septembre prochains à mantes la
jolie
au programme jacob desvarieux les ogres
de barback ou encore daniel zimmermann
le tout avec des mesures sanitaires
mises en place justin rasé une deuxième
édition pour les halls factory festival
le coup d'envoi de la manifestation sera
donné le 18 septembre prochain
au programme artistes de renommée
internationale ou locale mais aussi
trois créations
donc évidemment nathalie d'auxerre avec
du club qui sera le vendredi on aura
aussi j'ai pu goûter voire lieu ses amis
et la musique au pays
le samedi et on aura également une
création de clémentine de couture est
une chanteuse de deux d'opéra et de
musique classique mais qui travaillera
ce pour le reste du g20
si à l'origine le groupe têtes raides
devait jouer sur la grande scène les
artistes ont été contraints d'annuler
ils seront remplacés par les ogres de
barback le concert se déroulera le
dimanche 20 septembre à 20 heures
je dois vraiment remercier les ogres de
barback fronton qui ont un vrai une
vraie volonté de solidarité de soutien
pour le festival qui savent le travail
qui est déployée par les organisateurs
et ans et qui ont vraiment envie de
continuer là assaisonner leurs liens
avec leur public et donc c'est pour ça
que
ou accepté avec grand plaisir de
s'adapter et de venir au festival
contexte sanitaire oblige des
dispositifs ont été mis en place pour
respecter les gestes barrières notamment
le port du masque obligatoire ou encore
un nombre de spectateurs limité il a
fallu tout tout tout remodeler en tant
que plan donc et et pour assurer la
sécurité du public donc il va y avoir
distanciation il va y avoir des départs
cours pour que les gens ne puissent pas
se croiser il va y avoir du nettoyage
aussi sur l'ensemble du site du festival
des points de gel hydroalcoolique
beaucoup de mesures qu'on connaît le
festival se déroule du 18 au 20
septembre programme et réservations sur
eole factory festival.com c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de votre fidélité
belle soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]